welcome to the second lecture first
we'll cover just some logistics so
homework one will be posted today and
it's going to be due Monday October 7th
and will cover actually some of the
topics that will be in homework 1 today
so pay attention if you want to be able
to do homework 1 tael preferences for
papers by tomorrow so that we can start
assigning papers to you well well assign
papers as quickly as possible especially
for the first group that's presenting on
Thursday next week also a reminder that
the tensorflow review session is
tomorrow on at 4:30 p.m. in gates bo3
that's going to be led by us and then
lastly for enrollment if you filled out
the form and have not received a
permission code then at this point I
bless you fill out the code like a
minute ago I think we've handled
basically all of the cases so just send
this send the staff an email or a post
on Piazza asking about that and we can
look at that at a case-by-case basis if
you need to if you still haven't filled
out the form please do fill it out
although at this point um maybe let us
know if you filled it out because we may
not be monitoring it quite as frequently
ok any logistical questions before we
yeah
the homework will be due midnight on
Monday October 7th and the date will
also be post the time and date will be
posted on the new assignment ok great so
the plan for today we actually have a
lot of material to cover so first we'll
be talking about some of the basics of
multitask learning things like the types
of the types of models and architectures
that these algorithms typically use as
well as how we actually do it go about
the training process for multi task
learning some of the tone does that
arise when you try to train across
multiple tasks and a case study of
actually trying to use multi task
learning in a real-world application and
some of the challenges that come up and
some of the results that were there then
we'll have a short break around like two
minutes or so and then we'll be covering
some topics some kind of basic topics
and metal learning we'll get into more
advanced topics in future lectures this
will include things like the meta
learning problem formulation a general
recipe of meddler nning algorithms and
kind of how you go about building these
types of algorithms and then lastly
we'll talk about a specific class of
metal learning algorithms called that
I'm gonna refer to as blackbox
adaptation approaches and these last two
things actually how you go about setting
up a meta learning algorithm and
implementing it a simple approach to my
learning that will be the topic of
homework 1 ok so let's get started with
multi task learning so it actually
before we even get into multi task
learning let's look at some notation so
say we have some neural network the
neural network is going to take in some
input X and produce some output Y and
the input might be something like a
picture maybe the output is the class
corresponding to that picture of the
class of the animal for example another
example of an input might be like the
title of a paper for example maybe
you're trying to decide which papers to
read or or which papers that you want to
review and then you kind of want to
decide whether or not the papers gonna
be too long or not this is essentially a
variety of classification type problems
you might imagine the weights of the
network will use theta to denote the
weights and then you can basically view
this neural network as producing a
distribution over outputs Y given the
input X of course this could also be a
deterministic function viewing it as a
distribution as a generalization of a
deterministic function okay so in single
test learning the way that you this
would mostly be review for all of you so
single test learning at least a
supervised single test learning problem
we have assumed some data set where we
have input-output pairs and we probably
have many input/output pairs
corresponding to that data set and our
goal is to minimize some loss function
that is a function of the parameters and
the data set we want to minimize that
loss function with respect to the
parameters and so one typical loss
function that we may use is something
that
looks like negative log likelihood so
our loss function is going to correspond
to the expectation of the data points in
our data set of the log probability of
our predictions the log probability of
the labels under our neural network
predictor given the input okay so this
is kind of standard single task learning
the way that you would typically
optimize this log likelihood is that
back propagating into the parameters of
the network and running something like
SGD or your favorite optimizer Adam out
of grab momentum whatever all right so
now what actually call a task we talked
about this a little bit I last time on
Monday and we'll try to talk about this
a little bit more formally this time so
the way that we're going to define a
task for the sake of basically the first
half of this course before we get to
reinforcement learning is something that
looks like this where we're gonna have
some distribution over our inputs a
distribution of over the labels given
the inputs and a loss function and
essentially these two distributions P
are going to correspond to the true data
generating distributions and so of
course we don't actually have access to
these data distribution data generated
distributions but it allows us to kind
of reason about what we're gonna be
seeing at training and test time in
particular what we're gonna be seeing
the kind of things that we will have
access to is we'll have a training set
in a test set for each task and we'll
assume that each of these distributions
are drawn from the same data generating
distribution P or P I so essentially
what a different task corresponds to a
different task may vary based off of the
input distribution the label
distribution given the input or the loss
function okay one notational note is
that we're all in future slides I'll be
using di as shorthand for the training
data set and yeah we'll get to that in
that code in a couple of minutes any
questions on kind of the basic setup
yeah oh that just means that we're
defining the task to be equal to getting
on the right okay so this is our task
task in freeze toss we have
corresponding datasets sampled from some
distribution let's look at kind of some
examples of what different tasks may be
in particular what different sets of
tasks may be what kind of different
problems may correspond to so for
example we may have a multi task
classification problem where we want to
be able to perform different
classification tasks and in this case
the loss function will be the same
across all the tasks the loss function
will be something like cross-entropy
loss for all the tasks but the the
inputs like the images that you're
seeing for each task or the labels
corresponding to those inputs may vary
across different tasks for example may
be different tasks corresponding
correspond to writing to be able to
recognize handwriting digits on a per
language basis maybe you want it like
one task is to be able to recognize have
characters corresponding to Braille for
example while another corresponds to
another language another multi task
classification task might be like a
personalized spam filter the emails that
I get are probably very different than
the emails that a high schooler gets for
example or like a professional athlete
for example and so the types of spam
will be different so classifying spam
for one person could be one task and
classifying spam for another person
could be a different task in that case
the loss function is the same across all
tasks the P of X is different because
the types of emails that each person
will be receiving the distribution of
emails will be different so you'll have
a different P I of X for each person and
also different things might be one print
one thing that might be spam for one
person might not be spam for the other
person and so you may have a different P
P I of Y given X okay so that's one
example another example of a multi-dose
learning problem is what's called
multi-label learning in this case the
loss function
and the distribution over the inputs is
going to be the same across tasks and
what's going to be different is you're
going to want to be able to make
predictions
they're basically able to pick different
labels different perform different kind
of output that tasks given your input
image so one example of this is
attribute recognition so if you have a
data set of faces in this lab a data set
for example one task might be correspond
to detecting whether or not the person
is wearing hat another one might be
correspond to detecting their hair color
things like that so there are P of X is
the same the loss function is the same
but Y given X is different because you
have different binary classification
tasks another example is something like
scene understanding where maybe given an
image you want to be able to predict the
depth of that image to keep different
key points the surface normals of that
image as well so this is a common
problem in computer vision so both of
these examples where settings where the
loss function was actually consistent
across all tasks and what was varying
was the data distribution and so what
are settings where the loss function
might vary across the tasks so one
setting is maybe one of your tasks
corresponds to predicting a discrete
variable whereas another one corresponds
to predicting a continuous variable in
that case maybe one task one house might
have like a cross entropy loss function
whereas another might correspond to mean
squared error or or something more
sophisticated than that a different way
to represent likelihood essentially
another studying word that in my various
actually if you care more about one task
than another task maybe you care more
about accurately predicting the surface
normals then about the the depth for
example then you might kind of increase
the have a loss function weight
correspond one task that's higher than
the weight of another task okay so here
are some examples of kind of different
multi task classification or different
multi task learning problems that we
might want to solve how do you actually
go about solving them so we can go back
to our neural network and if we want to
run our neural network to do multiple
different things then we need to tell it
what it should do and so in some ways we
kind of needed
conditioned on the task in some way and
so what we're gonna have is we're gonna
have some tasks descriptor Z and we're
gonna pass this task which descriptor
into the neural network in some way and
so I'm just gonna draw an arrow towards
the neural network to indicate that and
in a minute we'll talk about different
ways that we can condition on that toss
descriptor and of course now our neural
network is not gonna be just a function
of X but it's also gonna be a function
of this task descriptor CI okay so for
example in this case maybe X kind of go
back to the the paper title example
maybe X corresponds to paper titles and
now instead of oh it's back okay
so maybe let's try it and try it instead
of trying to figure out what what paper
you want to read you now need to review
the paper and produce a review for a
conference and maybe you're a bit lazy
so you ask your neural network to
predict a summary of the paper for you
so that you can then base your review on
the summary or maybe maybe you're even
lazier and you just want to output the
paper review directly hopefully these
aren't the reviewers for your papers but
yeah okay so what is this task
descriptor thing the very simplest
example of what this task is your
descriptor might be is just a one hot
encoding of the task index just a vector
that tells you if it's task 1 task to
task 3 etc this is just kind of an index
corresponding to the task but more
generally it could also be whatever
metadata you have about that task if
your task corresponds to personalize a
personalization then the task descriptor
might include information about that
person or that user if it's something
maybe you have kind of a language
description at the task you want to
perform so you can provide that language
description to the network or maybe you
have some formal specification of the
tops like maybe you're trying to design
circuit it's like was I mentioned on
Monday then you might have kind of a
formal specification of the type of
circuits that you might want your neural
network to be producing ok
so this is the task group descriptor and
then our objective now becomes basically
the same as what it was before but now
we're gonna be summing over all of the
tasks that that we have alright so this
is the basic setup
now we have a couple design decisions to
make so we have a model and we have an
objective and so we have a decision for
both of them the first is how should we
design the model in the second is how
should we optimize the the objective so
particularly the big decision that we
have to make and multi-touch learning is
how do we condition on this task
descriptor Zi and the algorithm decision
like I mentioned is how do we optimize
our objective so let's first talk about
this this first question so this is all
about conditioning on the task let's
assume that Zi for now is just gonna be
the task index like a one hot encoding
our task index and we only know kind of
information about our task is this this
index basically so I have a question for
you which is how should you condition on
Zi in order to share as little as
possible between the tasks in your
neural network model essentially how
should you structure your neural network
model such that it shares basically as
little as possible between the different
tasks yep yeah exactly so what you can
do is you can have separate networks for
each task where the you have each each
of them have completely separate weights
and then the way that you condition on
your task descriptor is you pick the the
corresponding task which corresponds to
this sort of multiplicative gating where
you're just selecting which of the
outputs you're going to produce based
off of your your task index this is
basically a complicated way to say that
we're gonna scan be training independent
networks and it's kind of one way to
represent independent networks within a
single model essentially okay so we get
independent training within a single
neural network and there's no shared
parameters across tasks now what about
the other extreme so the other extreme
would be something like this where we
take our neural network and we just
concatenate the task index somewhere
either at the activations or
the input and then train the network as
normal and in this case all of the
parameters are shared except for one
tiny part of the parameter vector what
is the the kind of tiny part of the
parameters that's not shared sorry I
repeat that yeah exactly so basically
the weights that are right after this Zi
the kind of if you have a fully
connected layer right after Zi
concatenated with your features the the
part of that matrix that corresponds to
that is basically right after Zi will
have basically different different
components that are not shared for each
of the tasks other than that half of
that matrix all the other parameters are
shared yeah yeah yeah exactly so in this
case we assume that all the inputs have
the same size the same dimensions one
thing that you could do is if different
tasks have different sizes you can
basically like you can have some sort of
recurrent neural network or some sort of
attention based model that basically
aggregates over the variable dimension
like if you if one of them is time for
example it aggregates over that whereas
maybe some tasks have our text and
others-image
images in that case you would probably
want to have different different first
parts of that network to take in those
different modalities of data and we'll
show we'll see me like an explicit
example of how that has been done in the
past yeah
so this is yeah this is a good question
is it's it's a fairly nuanced point so
basically each you can make you can view
the first fully connected layer
corresponding to a weight matrix times a
vector and when you when you take the
the top part of that matrix will
correspond to or sorry the the left rows
of that the left columns of that matrix
will correspond to the the features and
the right columns of that will
correspond to the top task vector that's
being pasta in this innocent put and if
you essentially if the di is a one hot
vector then you'll have one entry in
that matrix that is one and there are
other entries in that in that vector
will be 0 and so basically all the ones
where all of the columns that have an
entry in Zi that corresponds to 0 will
be 0 not and won't be used for that task
whereas the columns that have the 1 will
be used for that task yeah technically
although if you kind of mathematically
go through the gradients the gradients
for those columns will be 0 for the
tasks in which for the tasks in which
the the input is 0 yeah exactly so Zi
was not a one hot vector for example
then you would have that part of the
matrix would be shared parameters
another kind of some one interesting
fact about this is if you could if you
concatenate Zi at every single layer of
the network you'll have more task
specific parameters whereas if you
condition it only on a single layer of
the network you only have kind of one
set of task Pacific parameters yeah
yeah exactly so the output of that that
part of the matrix is a linear transform
on the one hot which produces a vector
basically the well the column of that
matrix corresponds to the resulting
vector which can you give you as
essentially as an embedding a linear
embedding of that task yeah yeah so if
you add the AI to every layer then you
are you're increasing the number of
parameters per layer of course and
you're also like the parameters that
you're adding are all tasks well not
there they're not all TAS Pacific there
they're mostly task specific maybe like
like it depends on the dimensionality of
each vector it's somewhere around half
half of the new parameters are top
specific and half of the parameters are
shared so as you add weights to neural
networks they become more expressive as
you add task specific weights then in
some ways they become even more
expressive because for different tasks
they can represent completely different
things we'll get to that in a second
yeah okay
so we've been talking a lot about shared
parameters and and task specific
parameters and one kind of alternative
view on the multi task learning problem
is that you can split your parameter
vector into these shared parameters and
toss specific parameters we told you
know as theta SH and theta I and then if
you view if you view kind of that as
your parameter vector then your
objective looks something like this
which is basically exactly the same as
the previous objective but it decomposes
decomposes and makes it obvious that the
task specific parameters are only
optimized with respect to the objective
for that task whereas the sherry ammeter
czar optimized over for all I basically
optimize over all tasks so one of the
things that somewhat interesting to note
based on both of the examples that we
saw the the multiplicative gating
example as well as the concatenation
example is that choosing how you
condition on Z in many ways is
equivalent to choosing how and where to
share parameters yeah so essentially the
choosing a conditional on Z corresponds
to thinking about this sort of
optimization problem and thinking about
where those shared parameters should lie
and where those two specific parameters
should lie okay so let's go over a few
more choices for how how we might go
about conditioning things so we saw how
we could do concatenation based
conditioning where I basically take that
tas descriptor and concatenate it with
the features and then do a linear layer
after that another option to
concatenation based conditioning is to
add the is to add the the task reference
vector to your to your hidden units to
your features or you basically have a
linear layer to make sure that those
feet that kind of says that you can
basically add it on in such as it's the
same dimensionality because the
dimensionality of Z I may not be the
dimensionality features you run through
that linear layer and then add it
interestingly I presented both of these
as two different two different options
but they're actually just the same thing
so you can essentially view additive and
concatenation based conditioning the
same so for example on the left side of
this figure you see that your
concatenated x and z and then you have
this weight matrix that corresponds to
the corresponds to the kind of the
weights that are applied to each of
those layers and you can view that as
you kind of apply the matrix multiplied
to those two parts of the vector you
basically get
these two components that are added
together which illustrates how how
basically the right hand side of this
figure corresponds to the additive
conditioning which is equal to the left
hand side which is a concatenation based
conditioning okay yeah yes so this is
assuming as either one hot vector yeah
absolutely so if you have more
information about how tasks are similar
or dissimilar from one another then you
can feed that into your network as
opposed to Zi interestingly determining
how similar tasks are to tasks are to
each other is actually a big part of the
multitask learning problem itself is
kind of determining how you should be
sharing sharing content sharing
parameters sharing structure across
these different tasks and in many and
multitask problems you don't necessarily
have that a priori but there are there
certainly have many examples and we'll
actually see a practical example where
you do have some information about the
task and you can use that to condition
your network on in a different way okay
a couple other very common conditioning
choices this is again for the one hot
case where you don't have a lot of
information about how two tests are
shared one is kind of a this form of
multitask or multi-head architecture
where you have some set of parameters
and then you split off the network into
into different heads the citation here
is for 2017 that's just for the visual
this has been something that people have
used for a long time and then one other
interesting choice or one other kind of
very common choice that you can do is
multiplicative conditioning which is
basically identical to additive
conditioning except instead of adding
you multiply so you project your task
matrix
your task vector onto
a vector and then you multiply that onto
your onto the activations either in the
input or a kind of intermediate
representations of your neural network
okay so why might this sort of multiple
could have a conditioning be a good idea
there's actually a few different reasons
so one is it's more expressive than
additive conditioning you can represent
multiplicative interactions whereas with
additive things you can you it's much
harder essentially and the other reason
is if you think about something like
multiplicative gating that we talked
about before this sort of gating is
something that can very naturally be
represented by multiplicative
conditioning and not just multiplicative
gating but also things like a multi head
architecture where you want to basically
be choosing which parts of the network
should be to be used for different tasks
it's essentially the sort of
multiplicative conditioning where you're
multiplying this embedding antero
activations allows it to modulate
different features such that you can
completely turn off features you
completely only use some heads for one
task only use some parts of the network
for one task versus another task yeah
that's a good question I would say it's
a very simple form of attention
mechanism I think attention mechanisms
usually involve dot products and in this
case you're not actually something
across the regions you're just doing an
element-wise multiplication yeah
yeah you can definitely do that and
we'll see an example of that in in the
case study actually and multiplicative
conditioning allows you to do that
Alette allows it to actually learn how
to do that in a completely automatic way
yeah yeah as as expressive as the
additive or right so these diagrams have
been kind of looking at a single layer
at a time of course when you add neuron
add kind of layers and your neural
network is a universal function
approximator and so if you concatenate
two things and then want to give you the
product a neural network can represent
that function and so technically the
additive function Network can also
represent this when you concatenate it's
just in practice and so technically all
of these are kind of all Universal
function approximator --zf or in the
multitasking in many ways it's kind of
more about what you're readily allowing
the network to do and how kind of the
optimization process itself although
it's much harder to say things about
optimization then then about the types
of things that like an individual layer
can represent for example yeah
can you repeat the question
that's how see that you haven't seen any
trading data for so yes so that's a good
question
in that case if you want to be able to
generalize to an entirely new task that
you haven't seen during training you'll
need something other than a one hot
vector because if you only have a one
hot back there then you're you don't
know how that new task relates to
anything that you've done before but if
you have a language description for
example then then in principle these
these models could learn how to
generalize from basically given a new
language description to perform that
task given enough data of other language
descriptions that share that share
commonalities with what you're seeing at
test time and then in the second part of
this lecture we'll be talking about how
we can quickly learn new tasks from data
by using experience on on costly on
previously seen tasks okay there are
also more complex choices that we can go
with as well so here are some
architectures from from the literature
for example these things include various
modules various attention components
different gating mechanisms we don't
have time to go through all of the
possible choices that you could do here
although some of the I think one or two
of the of the readings that we'll have
we'll cover a couple different options
there yeah so the main takeaway though
that I'd like to give is that there are
like s1 there are a lot of different
approach like a lot of different choices
we have to make when choosing the
architecture and unfortunately these
design decisions are basically kind of
correspondent role network architecture
tuning in that they are problem
dependent so when architecture will work
well and one problem but won't
necessarily work well on another problem
or another set of multi another set of
tasks in many ways are largely
by intuition or knowledge of the problem
so if you know the two tops are similar
you might have them share more whereas
if you know that top two tops are
different you might have them share less
and I would say that currently is in
some ways more of an art than a science
and there there isn't kind of like any
guide that can tell you exactly how to
how to do this given a new prop a new
set of tasks that you want to be able to
learn but hopefully in this is a very
active area of research and hopefully in
the kind of coming years we'll have
better a better idea for how to do this
okay so now that we've talked about the
model architecture a lot what about
actually optimizing the subjective in
many ways is is fairly straightforward
compared to standard neural network
training kind of a very basic version of
optimizing this objective would
correspond to first sampling a mini
batch of tasks so we have different
tasks menu just sample different tasks
and then sample data points for each
task so I'm alone unlike the standard
supervised setting we won't just be
sampling kind of sampling once we'll be
sampling twice then we're going to
compute our loss function on our mini
batch by kind of measuring a stochastic
basically kind of getting a stochastic
gradient rather than a rather than the
true beauty because we can't evaluate
the gradient on our entire data set we
back propagate the loss to compute the
gradient and then apply the gradient to
your parameters using your your favorite
neural network optimizer so basically
this is the same as standard single test
learning except that were to be sampling
a batch of tasks and about your data
points for each of those tasks and note
that kind of these first two steps is
ensure that the tasks are sampled
uniformly regardless of data quality so
if you have one task that has a lot more
data than another task then this will
ensure that you're sampling them at
equal rates which is what we're
optimizing for in on the top if you care
more about the top that has more data
than of course it makes sense to weight
those differently and sample at
different proportions as well okay
and one other tip here is that if you're
a different task correspond to
regression problems this isn't really
necessarily specific to the optimization
algorithm but it's pretty important to
make sure your task labels are on the
same scale otherwise inherently your
loss function is going to have a greater
scale for which the the labels have a
greater magnitude okay so now that we've
gone over kind of the basics of the
architectures and the challenges or the
architectures and the algorithms let's
talk about some of the challenges to
come up so the MA was a kind of number
one challenge that I view with
multi-touch learning is the problem of
negative transfer and this kind of the
symptom of this is when like if you
train independent networks and that's
doing better than your multitask
learning method then that means that
you're getting negative transfer it
means that the kind of data and training
from one task is adversely hurting its
adversely affecting the training of the
other tasks so for example and this is
actually a problem that is quite
prevalent and in some cases maybe you
care more about computational efficiency
it's not practical to train independent
networks but for example we were
actually recently trying to write a
paper on multi task learning there's
this common multi task version of the
CFR dataset where you break it down into
when the different task corresponding to
the different kind of upper level
categories of CFR and we kind of
evaluated all this to a multiple stage
the aren't approaches for multi task
learning and got various levels of
accuracy on this data set and then we
trained independent networks and it was
performing better than kind of all of
the recent papers so why why does this
happen
why does negative transfer like why
aren't we actually getting benefit from
training across multiple tasks one is
optimization challenges so if if
basically gradients of one task are
interfering with the with the training
of another task basically when you apply
it you
great for task 1 compute gradient for
toss to if gradient 1 Hertz the weights
for toss to then the optimization will
be more difficult and also tasks may
learn at different rates so if one
tosses learning a lot faster than
another task you might end up learning
one task very quickly and then it might
get stuck trying to learn toss 2 because
it's kind of already learned something
and it doesn't want to learn something
else essentially kind of the
optimization get stuck since it's it's
kind of in this local optimum ok
I mean the other issue that you might
run into is maybe you have limited
representational capacity so multi task
networks in general often need to be
much larger than single task networks
this is very intuitive but it's can be
easy easy to forget and in this case the
D if it isn't as large as it needs to be
then you're going to see underfitting
and that's a kind of a symptom of
limited representational capacity yeah
yeah
so let's say good question about
basically how to handle like
authorization tongs especially when one
task was more data than another one is
kind of the thing that I mentioned
before is you sampled samples the tasks
and basically balanced them such that
they have the same amount of data such
that doesn't favor one task over the
other because oftentimes if you if you
don't do that then it will learn the
task that has a lot of data and we won't
learn the other one people have explored
curriculum learning techniques and we'll
talk a bit about that later on in this
course
in general the I would say that the
optimization challenges aren't
completely well understood we're still
trying to understand Kevin general the
single task optimization landscapes let
alone the multi task optimization
landscapes I do think though that there
has been a lot like I'm actually pretty
optimistic about being able to
understand these sorts of challenges
very soon and we may even like later in
the course cover try to get a better
understanding of these optimization
challenges and how to mitigate them
performance with
you have there's like extra information
that maybe the network's into larger
networks but how do you compare so
you're saying that you're like why would
you expect positive transfer why would
you yeah so why don't we sin to expunge
situation to expect positive transfers
when you don't have a lot of data per
task and so if the tasks are related
enough then the feature is learned for
one task will be useful or the
representations learnt for one task will
be useful for the other task so it's
essentially a way to share data and as
well talked about in like two slides you
can basically kind of another way to
view multi task learning is essentially
a form of regularization and the if if
your kind of problem setting if
regularization would be helpful
basically and more data would be helpful
then those are some of the settings
where you definitely expect positive
transfer generalization essentially yeah
in reinforcement learning we'll see
other benefits as well relating to
exploration yeah that's a good question
so you mean all the same inputs but not
the different labels
yeah so in that case you can definitely
still see benefits from multitask
learning essentially each task with his
own form of supervision and what I was
talking about data sharing it's it's
it's not necessarily actually about
sharing inputs is about sharing
supervision and so if you have basically
each of those tasks correspond to
different amounts of supervision and
that those can be used for building more
flexible representations more powerful
representations it could be used for for
better solving one of your tasks yeah
yeah you can definitely do that in
practice fine tuning I'll talk a bit
about fine tuning next lecture and
practice that makes fewer assumptions
about the availability of data cuz you
assume that you can't kind of access
that first data set and so in practice
many times if you have both data sets
available you should use both of them
and you'll be able to get better
performance yeah
yeah that's a very good question uh my
LD that this question is necessarily
known I think that there may be our
techniques where we could better get a
sense for this before training but my
sense is that how similar two tasks are
is intimately tied to how easy it is to
learn them together and so I guess the
pessimistic side of me would answer that
it's actually not possible to a priori
know how much you should share ahead of
time but I think it's is kind of the
more optimistic side of me that says
that kind of the optimizer should be
able to figure it out throughout like in
an online fashion throughout
optimization during the learning process
so I don't think we can probably do it
before learning but I think it can't
happen during the learning process yeah
so it certainly could be that larger
networks help because they alleviate
optimization challenges um people have
observed in general and singles house
learning that if you have a larger
network they actually sometimes optimize
faster than the smaller networks but
separate from optimization there is also
just the representational capacity of
like if you're doing a single task
that's one function and if you're doing
another task
assuming that task is different the
representational capacity need to
represent both of those functions is
greater than just an individual function
but it may be that actually the
optimization colleges potentially could
even have a greater impact on on this
sort of observation yep
not off the top of my head but there
there certainly could be literature on
that given the extent to which people
have studied it yeah I feel free to like
post out on Piazza or something we can
try to find something I do suspect that
we won't be able to find an example with
real data in real problems yeah yeah
yeah I think that that would be
interesting yeah
in principle yes if you use most kind of
multiplicative conditioning so in
principle it does have the
representational capacity to represent a
completely separate networks and that's
that actually is one of the good reasons
to use that sort of gating the in
practice the optimizer might have
challenged finding that that solution
yeah and so it may not actually be able
to to find that solution but technically
it should have that capacity and I guess
one thing I will add to that is we
actually have observed very recently
that in many cases it's actually very
challenging for the optimizer to find
that solution in tasks where the where
the type the things that you're learning
are very distinct from one another yeah
so you can combine them but very naively
and stupidly by just kind of using a
toss collector to pick which one you
want but network you want to use to my
knowledge there aren't any technique
well I don't know of any we'll cover
this when we get to reinforcement
learning yeah so there are some
techniques that that do kind of take to
trade networks for tasks and then try to
learn a single network that fuses them
in some way okay I should probably get
on to the next few slides so the
takeaway here is you I I don't even know
if he viewed and said this yet but I
think all you have inferred it is that
if you have negative transfer you can
share less across tasks train a bigger
network and one of the interesting
things here is actually sharing versus
not sharing parameters is not just a
binary decision you could actually also
do what's called soft parameter sharing
and so what this looks like or one
version of this is where you have you
can break down your objective as
before in destroyed parameters and toss
specific parameters and then basically
add this term that encourages the toss
specific parameters to be similar to one
another and you could do this at
different layers of the network you
could do it for different pairs of tasks
for some pairs but not other pairs you
could also do it with respect to a
single set of global parameters and tie
them all to a single set of global
parameters instead of doing the sort of
pairwise loss and so what this looks
like is you have two separate networks
and what you do is you kind of softly
constrain the weights to be similar to
one another rather than actually having
them represent the same exact value so
one of the benefits of this is allows
for more fluid degrees of parameter
sharing where if you set the weight on
this loss this this right had lost a
zero then you have 0 parameter sharing
if you set it to be a very high value
such that essentially constraining the
optimization to set them such that
they're equal then that corresponds to
hard parameter sharing the downside is
that it's kind of yet another set of
decisions
hyper parameters that you need to tune
and and make sense of when you're
thinking about your your algorithm okay
and so now that I've talked about
negative transfer another problem which
is in many ways some one orthogonal of
this chawl or kind of the opposite of
this challenge is the challenge of
overfitting and so if you observe that
if you have a totally small amount of
data per task and you find yourself
overfitting to those tasks then it
actually may be that you're not sharing
enough it may be that you just need more
data but it may be that if you shared
more that would act as a stronger form
of regularization and you may be able to
overfit less okay so now I want to go
into kind of a case study of actually
applying these sorts of multitask
learning algorithms in practice and so
this was actually a very recent paper
that came out in the past two months and
they were looking at making
recommendations to users for YouTube and
this team is actually is from Google and
to my knowledge this is some of kind of
what we'll be covering here are some of
the decisions that they have made would
actually making recommendations to users
yeah so here's an example you have
you're kind of watching this this
lecture on deep learning and then on the
right you might be getting some
recommendations about what video to
watch next so there are a couple
challenges that come up in this sort of
problem and the way that they formulate
it as a multi x problem is predicting
it's making predictions about user
engagement and about user satisfaction
so you essentially have these
conflicting objectives to think about
should I generate a video that a user
will rate highly can I predict whether
or not the users will share that whether
or not they'll watch that video and the
types of things that you share are not
necessarily the types of things that you
would watch for a long period of time
for example the second choice that comes
up that I won't have a lot of time to
talk about today but it's also a bit
interesting is that in these sorts of
recommendation systems you also have a
form of feedback loop where users may
have watched something simply because
you recommended it and this leads to
bias in your data and so they also have
an interesting technique that they used
to address this bias and if you want to
kind of find out more information about
that you can look at the paper okay so
how do they actually set up this problem
in this framework so the input is what
the user is currently watching which is
called the query video and they also
know some features for that user and
then what they do is they first generate
candidate a few hundred candidate videos
that they might think that user might
want to watch they then rank the
candidates and then they serve the top
ranking videos to the user in that
recommendations bar on the right the kid
at videos this wasn't really the main
focus of the paper but the way that they
do this is they pull videos from
multiple multiple candidate generation
algorithms these algorithms do things
like try to match topics of the video
that you're currently watching they also
try to look at the videos that are most
frequently watched together with the
video that you're currently watching as
well as well as a number of other forms
of metrics and then kind of the central
topic of this paper was given a large
number of kin
videos can you rank can you figure out
what basically ranked the those
candidates and to an ordered list where
the top things correspond to the ones
you actually want to serve okay
so how do you actually formulate the
ranking problem what this looks like
again similar to before your input is
gonna consist of the query video and
features of the user it's also going to
have the input is also going to be one
of the candidate videos so this is gonna
be operating on each of the candidate
videos and interestingly in this case
things like the query video in the
candidate video these are actually
literally the videos they correspond to
information about those videos like
features of the video such as the topic
the title the upload time and then also
user features like user and context
features such as their user profile the
time of day and a variety of other
things so this includes both textual
data as well as non textual data that
they have used kind of different shared
embedding network to embed into a common
representation space and the output of
this model to determine the engagement
and satisfaction of the candidate video
for the user
after watching the query video and so
engagement include things like whether
or not they clicked on the candidate
that the served video whether or not
they spent time watching that video so
this is both classification and
regression and the satisfaction
correspond to things like clicking like
on that video as well as rating that
video for example so again this is both
a kind of a mixed discrete and
continuous problem and then kind of the
big question is how do you figure out
the score from these from these
different metrics and what they do is
they actually just use a very simple
weighted combination of these
predictions where the weights of those
predictions are just manually tuned and
the the reason why the kind of the
motivation that they had here is that
the the system is very complex itself
and also the the metrics for like for
weather
not for whether or not you're actually
serving good videos are online metrics
and they're ones that you cannot that
are very difficult to optimize with
respect to and so by doing this in a way
that's kind of done manually it's a bit
simpler it's it's easier to kind of to
to iterate on the on the model
essentially okay so let's talk about the
kind of how do we actually predict
engagement in satisfied so they
considered some basic option which
corresponds to the multi-head
architecture that we talked about before
where you have some shared layers and
also some layers that are predicting
engagement and and satisfaction this was
kind of their baseline and one of the
things that they found is that when the
correlation between the toss is low that
will harm the learning process as we've
kind of talked about before is sort of
negative transfer right and so what they
did instead is they used a form of soft
parameter sharing and this looks like
this where and I'll go through the
details kind of step-by-step so you have
some shared bottom layer and the goal is
of kind of the sort of mixture of
experts model is to allow different
parts of the network to specialize so
you have these different expert neural
networks that you want to specialize in
different meet in different ways so you
kind of you can see this example has two
different experts then you want side
which expert to use for an input and for
a given task okay and so what this
corresponds to is you have a different
sort of wait matrices for each task and
you have an input and you do a linear
combination and the softmax to produce
this this distribution over which expert
to use and then you compute the features
from the selected expert so you this
this bottom layer corresponds to sorry
that the expert corresponds to fi of X
you then multiply this with the gating
function in order to produce the kind of
the selected expert output and then
lastly you compute the output of this so
then you take another neural network H
it's gonna take the output of the expert
and produce the result so this is an
example of an architecture that starts
out as shared branches out into multiple
multiple experts we're at maximum eight
it may use multiple it may use just a
single expert and then comes back it to
a single part of the model okay so in
the experiments the the setup here was
actually quite interesting they use
tensorflow and TP use as you might
expect they trained in temporal order
where they're feeding in the videos over
time and training continuously to
consume the newly arriving data and they
said that this is really important so
that because the distribution over time
of user engagement is changing as as
different trends become popular etc they
had various offline and online metrics
for offline they looked at a you see for
classification tasks and squared error
metric metrics for regression tasks but
the most important things were actually
the online metrics because those were
actually the ones that you ultimately
care about and so they did a be testing
in comparison to their production system
and the the live metrics for this online
testing correspond to things like the
time spent on on YouTube survey
responses that different users filled
out and the rate of dismissals which I
guess would kind of relate to whether or
not they're actually kind of dismissing
suggestions or by the recommender system
and then the last thing you worth noting
here is because this is a massive system
computational efficiency also really
matters and so this is one of the
reasons why they didn't consider
independent training and why they really
wanted to do multi tossed training such
that they didn't have to basically
compute everything separately for all of
these different metrics okay so here are
the results so the the top T rows are
showing the the baseline networked at
hot that correspond to a multi head
Network and the bottom two are
corresponding to the mixtures of mixture
of experts architecture what we see is
that there's a substantial increase in
and in satisfaction at around point four
percent and three percent for the larger
mixture of experts model which is which
is nice to see it also they looked at
how different tasks are utilizing the
different experts so each of these bars
correspond to a different task so you
can see that expert seven is typically
doing things for task four and for task
1 whereas expert 2 is typically
computing features for task two and for
task 3 and then lastly they found a 20%
of this sort of gating polarization
where each expert would would kind of
you you basically actually like not use
an expert at all and what they found is
that if they use some sort of drop out
such that to prevent it from like only
using kind of one expert for all the
tasks so we're not using one expert at
all this was was helpful for mitigating
that okay yeah sorry can you repeat the
question
yeah so I think that what they mean by
polarization here is that they're
actually using one expert for all of the
tasks or not using one expert at all
okay let's take a quick like one-minute
break you guys have been asking a lot of
questions which is awesome and then
we'll try to get into some mid learning
give an example of the other recommend a
recommender system I don't have a I
didn't in reading the paper I guess I
didn't have a sense for if they did a
comparison of this approach versus other
things like collaborative filtering but
I guess I would occur to you to take a
look closer look at the paper to see if
they they talked about that okay let's
get started on the second part so let's
talk about my learning we may not have
time to get through everything but if we
don't at all I'll cover what we didn't
cover at the beginning of lecture on
Monday okay um so to start off in many
ways I think that are kind of two ways
to view meta learning algorithms one is
somewhat of a mechanistic view and
another is somewhat of a probabilistic
view so the mechanistic view is a view
that I think is very helpful for
figuring out how you actually go about
implementing one of these algorithms and
really understanding kind of the
underlying mechanics of how things work
and how the implementation works and the
probabilistic view I find to be very
helpful for understanding conceptually
and intuitively what these algorithms
are doing and so the the kind of
mechanistic view is that you kind of
have this deep neural network that reads
in data sets and make makes predictions
for new data points such that when you
see a new data set and you can make
predictions for new data points and
training for this network uses a
a set of data sets each for a different
task and yeah as I said this makes it
easier to implement meta learning
algorithms
whereas kind of at a high level the
probabilistic view is looking at metal
learning as learning priors essentially
learning priors over tasks that in a way
that enables kind of combining that
prior with a small amount of data for a
new task in order to more efficiently
learn yeah so kind of learning a task
for a new prior use a small amount of
data and I find that kind of thinking
about it from a patient perspective and
make it a bit easier to understand
what's going on so I'm gonna start with
the probabilistic view to give some
intuition for what these algorithms are
doing and then I'll go into the more
mechanistic view of actually how you
implement these algorithms so for the
first part don't worry about how you
would actually go about implementing
things it's more about some of the the
conceptual aspects of things so we're
gonna kind of go back to problem
definitions here and kind of redefine
things from a page in perspective in
order to view meta learning as a major
perspective so you can view supervised
learning as a maximum likelihood problem
where you're maximizing the likelihood
of your parameters given your data and
in this case Phi is going to be the
model parameters and D is gonna be the
data set and of course it's kind of as
before the data set contains XY pairs we
have inputs and labels and you can also
view this kind of redefine it as
maximizing the probability of the data
given your parameters and maximizing the
marginal probability of your parameters
so the first term is your data
likelihood and the second term may be
something like a regular Iser it's like
something like weight decay for example
which corresponds to putting a Gaussian
prior on your weights with a fixed
variance okay and so then what this
looks like is you have some optimization
over your data set and given your
weights and then you have your regular
Iser unfortunately if your data is very
large as we come if you're sorry if your
dataset is very
small as we talked about then you might
over fit to that dataset and even if you
have a regular Iser there it may not be
enough to prevent you from overfitting
or it may not it may kind of that not be
informative enough of actually what you
should be learning or kind of the model
that you're trying to learn so the
question in meta learning and kind of
the key problem that is trying to answer
is when we're solving supervised
learning problems can we incorporate
additional data in some way like maybe
we're not learning from scratch maybe we
have experience from from before that
we've kind of experienced the world
before we're at this point and that's
what it was gonna be called the
Mediterranean data we want to be able to
use the Mediterranean data such that
when we perform a new task we can learn
it more effectively and more efficiently
and in particular though in in meta
learning lis this additional data is
actually going to correspond to a set of
data sets basically a set of tasks or
data's data sets correspond to tasks we
want to be able to use those data sets
such that when we see a data for a new
task we can learn parameters for that
task and then of course each of these
individual data point each of these
individual data sets will have K data
points so for example if you want to
solve a few shots classification problem
maybe you're given five images and you
want to be able to classify new images
as being among one of those five classes
if you try to train a neural network
from scratch on this problem it will
either overfit massively or if your
regularizer is too strong it won't do
anything but if you have data from other
image classes like shown here then and
this is your Mediterranean data then you
might be able to use that Mediterranean
data in a way that allows you to learn
from only five examples in a manner that
is effective and of course this doesn't
need to be image classification problems
this could be different kind of sinusoid
prediction problems it could be really a
variety of other problems that may lie
dual language classification or kind of
yeah decoding text or exact
it's a try okay so that's kind of the
problem that we want to solve but what
if we don't want to keep keep around our
past experience forever what if we if
we're gonna be trading on on all of our
past experience across tasks then we
don't want to assume that we could have
to access that every time we want to
learn a new task and so what we're going
to do is we're going to try to kind of
compile our Mediterranean data set down
to a set of parameters data which I'm
gonna call the medic
parameters and data is basically a
correspond to whatever we need to know
about the Mediterranean data in order to
solve a new task quickly so basically if
you kind of view the if you want to
introduce this kind of intermediary
variable if we write out the likelihood
of our our parameters for our data set
given our pasta our pasta meta training
data we can write this out in a way that
integrates over our meta parameters
theta so we first infer our meta
parameters theta given our military data
and then we can make predictions of our
prediction about our kind of our task
parameters given our data and our meta
parameters and note that this assumes
that the our task specific parameters
and our Mediterranean date are
conditionally independent based a
conditioned on theta and we can
basically approximate this integral with
this is a fairly crude approximation but
we can approximate this integral with a
point estimate for our meta parameters
where the first that's kind of the
right-hand side of this is going to
correspond to Mediterranean where we
want to learn a set of meta parameters
given our Mediterranean data and the
left hand side of this objective is
going to correspond to adaptation where
we want to be able to learn new
parameters for a new task given data
from that task and our meta parameters
theta star okay where theta star is
equal to basically Arg max of log P
theta given our Mediterranean data okay
so essentially this right hand side is
the meta learning problem or optimizing
over our meta parameters such that when
we use them for for adaptation we can
effectively learn pram
for that task okay so méditerranée is
that kind of a second term it and an
adaptation is that is the term now
outlined in red let's first go over how
we can go about adaptation so we can
kind of look at a very simple example
and we'll revisit this example at the
end so say we want to be able to make
predictions about test data points the
parameters corresponding to this neural
network will correspond to fiestar
they'll be the parameters for that task
and we want to be able to infer these
parameters from data so one very simple
example for how we might prefer these
parameters from data is by training a
neural network to take in the data set
and output Phi I star or PI star for
that task and so for each of these
examples correspond to our data set and
so essentially what this would
correspond to is you would have kind of
these different military and data sets
for these days that they would pass that
into the neural network we would then
give it a new data point we want to be
able to have it make a prediction for
that data point based off of the
computed to a specific parameters so you
have this tier test input and then your
put your test label no but my question
is okay we have that this is kind of how
we're going to do that a patient process
how do we actually go about meta
training this this model so how do we
actually basically learn the parameters
of our recurrent neural network theta
star such that it produces the right
task specific parameters v star and so
the key idea here is we can basically
match test time to training time so if a
test time we're gonna be predicting Phi
star in order to make predictions about
test data points we wanna be able to do
the same thing at meditating and
basically train this recurrent neural
network such that it produces parameters
that lead to effective predictions or
accurate predictions so essentially the
key idea is that train and test
conditions should matter
that's basically like the good principal
role of meta learning basically if you
want to be able to earn the test time
you should basically train it to learn
during better training simply be
learning how to learn so and then you
can kind of view the learning process
the adaptation process is the sort of
meta test time if the former process is
met a train time okay right so the
process of optimizing for theta is meta
training the optimize for producing Phi
is meta testing now one of the things
that's pretty tell is if it met a
training time you're actually training
it to make predictions about test data
points where do those data points come
from how do we actually optimize for it
to make predictions on new data points
and the important thing here is that we
need to be able to simply reserve a test
set for each task that we're gonna be
better training over so if we have a set
of tasks and we have basically training
data for each task we also need
corresponding test sets for each of
those tasks and these test sets are
going to be held out images from those
same image categories now you might say
okay now you're gonna be testing
training on the test set this doesn't
seem right and that is that's a good
intuition to have but in this case we
now are now moving from Mediterraneans
from training sets to meta training sets
and test sets to meta test sets so each
of these tasks the training sets and the
test sets for the tasks correspond to
the meta training data set and then at
meta test time were given new tasks and
we don't want to train on the meta test
set okay so we have our Mediterranean
data this corresponds to training and
test sets for every task we're each of
the training set data set it's
corresponds to K data points each of the
test days days that's correspond to a
new set of K data points yeah okay
so the complete kind of optimization
problem is that a test time we're gonna
be inferring a set of top specific
parameters which could be some some
function that takes as input the
training dataset and outputs the top
specific parameters where the parameters
of that function or the meta parameters
are theta star and we essentially want
to learn a set of meta parameters such
that this function is good for held out
data points after being after getting
the training dataset as input okay
so essentially you can view theta star
as optimizing this objective where we
want to octave I optimize the the
probability of the parameters being
effective new data points okay cool so
you could also look at this as a
graphical model where theta is
essentially your prior Phi I is your
task specific parameters for a given
task and you have a train set and a test
set for for each task so Phi is five
leads to the data and theta acts as a
prior on the task specific parameters
for all the tasks theta is essentially
the information that's shared across
tasks okay and then this dashed line
just means that we don't know the test
labels for new tasks that met the test
time but we do know the training dataset
okay some terminology before I get into
some of the more mechanistic view of
metal earning so I talked about this we
call this the Mediterranean data set
each of these is each you brought each
of these rows as a meta training test
and each of these tasks has a
corresponding train set and test set the
the left side of these can be viewed as
the training data and the right side
could be viewed as the test data another
common terminology for this is support
set and query set where you have some
set of support images or training images
and some query images or test images and
if you have a case out learning problem
a few shot learning problem K is the
number of data points in your train data
set so if you're doing one-shot learning
you're doing your learning from one
example if you're doing K shot learning
you're learning from K examples okay how
does this relate to other problem
settings so multi tailoring like we
talked about the beginning of this
lecture you learn a model with with a
single set of parameters that solves
multiple tasks you don't care about
generalizing to new tasks and this
essentially can be seen as in somewhat
of a special cases meddler as meta
learning where your task specific
parameters and your your prior
parameters are the same
such that you're just kind of have a
single network that is representing all
of the tasks and in many ways mostly
house learning is a prerequisite for
medal earning because if you can't solve
the training tasks then you have no
chance of being able to learn new tasks
more efficiently than then like learning
from scratch for example it's also
related to things like hyper parameter
optimization and auto mo so in hyper
parameter observation you can
essentially these theta as the hyper
parameters and Phi is the network
weights and in architecture search you
could views data as the architecture Phi
is the network weights and both of these
are kind of a very active about areas of
research and outside of the scope of
this class not this tutorial okay I
think we're mostly out of time and so I
will cover the next two parts of the
lecture in the next lecture and we'll
probably push back the the due date for
the homework assignment I'd probably
like a couple days such that we you guys
have enough time to complete it are
there any questions about what I covered
with metal learning before we wrap up
okay
a couple quick reminders before you
leave the homework one is posted today
and is not due on Monday October 7th
fill out paper preferences by tomorrow
and the tensorflow review session will
also be too
at 4:30 p.m.